my name is john hadelburg and i create
replicas of dozens of famous diamonds
people think of gems as a commodity in
their in their smallest regard and
throughout history they've taken on so
much symbolism and they have many
different ways of related aspects of
people's lives so i try to bring many
different personalities and aspects to
gems
[Music]
hello everybody
diamonds are so incredibly brilliant and
the reason they're so brilliant is that
they're essentially a crystal lattice of
pure carbon
and that particular element in its its
cubic form when light comes into it it
slows the light down to replicate that i
have to come up with a material that can
give
the same quality of dispersion fire
white like brilliance i really think of
it as trying to replicate mona lisa's
smile
so
when someone asked me to make a replica
someone hands me a diamond and i'd make
a silicon mold of the top and bottom so
that gives me a negative of the actual
gem
from that
i pour a micro resin cast so it's
exactly the size and shape as the
original diamond and that becomes my
architectural model
once i have my
resin cast i can unlock all the original
angles and indices from the cutter
i love the fact that i'm completely
following the footsteps of
someone who had cut this origin in the
past whether the diamond was finished
last week or 500 years ago
so in the actual mapping it's the
process of reverse engineering
so i'm actually instead of putting the
crystal in the head and then starting to
cut it what i do is i put the cast of
the diamond in the head
and with something very technical called
a grease pencil i cover over a facet and
have it intersect with the lap and just
wait until the grease pencil just smears
off cleanly and then i know i have the
facet locked in
[Music]
i love making the map i love it in part
because
the end result is this beautiful drawing
that's another interpretation of the gem
itself so i enter the other cutter's
head
when i figure out the exact angles and
indices that he used and also with some
of the bigger diamonds especially in the
back of the stone the fastening's not
perfect
whether it's because the owner of the
diamond is looking over the shoulder
they want it done quickly so they'll
push a facet
kind of bend it so it's not flat it's
not perfect anymore or sometimes they'll
push a facet
so that they're not cutting away as much
material so they can make sure the stone
still weighs save 100 carats
i love those irregularities and if
they've pushed a facet i put it in also
so we're in my inner sanctum studio my
fastening table
my array of gems around me this is the
epicenter of my work so uh
here comes a little gem creation
i think of the tools of my trade versus
a number of my friends most of them were
jewelers mine's really basic my studio
is really only this big
and it's just a fastening machine
the wheels
the head
the powders the oils but it's all very
compartmentalized and organized
usually when i fasted a replica it takes
me at least six months i'm extremely
slow and i'm extremely
precise with what i do
so there's two real components of a
faster machine one is the head which is
the gem is glued onto a stick and
inserted into the head
and the other part of the fast machine
is the wheel or the lap and what you do
is you have the stone
intersect with the lap and so the two
ways you can regulate that is
the angle that the facet
hits the lap
and then if you turn the stone like this
and you can lock it into place hundreds
of different you know you can you can
split hairs in terms of where the
indices intersects the wheel so it's
those two the angle
and the indices
thank god it's a video because without
my arm movement people have no idea what
i've explained
the final step on making a replica
is you've finally polished
everything usually the last fast that i
finished is the largest one the table on
top of the stone and at that point i've
got to get it off of the stick off of
the dot stick and at that point i'm
kind of gasping because i can look at it
in the most critical of lights and see
that it's has a beautiful polishing is
done
in replicating diamonds
i think there's just been three
instances
where i had to start over because if you
cut below what the mass of the actual
diamond is then it can't be a perfect
replica anymore so it's just scrap heap
my access to famous diamonds can take a
long time the dresden green diamond for
example took me five years to get my
hands on it a town or diamond in london
that took me 13 years before i got
permission to work on it because there's
a certain diamonds i was chasing now
when i'm lucky enough to have someone
commission me to make a replica of the
famous diamond i always travel to the
diamond it's never brought here to uh to
the studio so the hope diamond of all
the gems i've been able to work on is my
most favorite wall and i've worked with
it
dozens of times so the hope diamond has
three iterations this is the first one
this is a copy and this is a color test
one of many to get the right color
so when this arrived tavernier one of
the generally famous diamond merchants
he made six voyages to india the last
one who came back had an audience with
louis xiv
and he sold him a huge diamond crystal
it was referred to vaguely as a
heart-shaped stone but you can see that
it resembles more of a crystalline shape
so what happened about four years after
louis xiv bought this it was refashioned
it was re-cut
and we have here the second iteration
this weighs about 65 carats so this is
one of the six stones in a six year
period that i've created for the
smithsonian
the crystal is actually very thin it's
so thin that no matter how you cut it
light will go right through it which you
want to avoid in any stone because it
decreases the brilliancy but what they
devised is louis xiv the sun king
his colors were blue and gold on the
back of this you can see this a seven
raid
sun the diamond obviously is blue and
because it's dead in the center the
light doesn't reflect through it they
had gold behind it
and that seven ray sun was projected so
it became the symbol of this rain it was
the gold sun in the blue sky
so then with a hope diamond and this is
a bit
odd this is
i i said how
when i work with the process of my
replica work someone hands me a diamond
i make a mold of it
i make a cast of it this is one of the
casts taken from the actual hope so this
is
100 accurate in terms of its size for
whatever reason i gold-plated it you
just sit this next to it
it's a six year project for the six gems
and completely a life dream of mine to
accomplish
so when someone gets to
look up close at a replication that
you've spent so much time on what do you
hope they take away from the experience
so i mean look at this
so this is a piece of chrysa cola from
new mexico it was mine in the 80s it's
an ore of copper
when i
look at this is you know a mineral
specimen amongst thousands of others
that i have around i can't believe that
it exists
it's
you know say it's like looking at a
flower
but you compare the beauty of a flower
in a gem and that mortal beauty is
ephemeral you have this second type of
beauty that will last forever that makes
it resonate in a different manner so
when i look at something like this i'm
really in awe that it exists
and that i get to take something that's
already perfect but make it so it's my
version of perfect by altering it
somehow this is a large part of my
aspiration as an artist
[Music]